welcome back to the show couple
education stories I want to cover we
don't always get the opportunity to talk
about education and I think maybe
because I've been doing some teaching
myself I am more and more sort of in the
world of paying attention to what's
going on with with education and
different aspects in different ways in
our country and there is a story out of
New Mexico that I wanted to tell you
about New Mexico proposed some new
science curriculum standards and they
were a complete and utter abomination
they included the deletion and omission
of global warming references the removal
of evolution references from science
class the removal of references to the
age of the earth according to science
which hint is not 6,000 years old but is
4.54 billion years old and as a result
of this and and this is a good thing you
would not necessarily expect that this
would happen because hey people have
lives and people are busy suggestions
from the public came in as they are
being called and I think a better way to
describe them would be angry demands
that you put that stuff back into the
science curriculum and it is indeed
going to happen the age of the earth as
science knows it he's going to be riad
'add to the new mexico science
curriculum the reality of the rise in
global temperatures over the last
century which is a component in climate
change is going to be added back in to
the new mexico science curriculum the
process of evolution is going to be
added back in so this is great news but
why were they removed in the first place
the the new revelation is that this
stuff is going to be put back in but a
better question would be why was it
removed in the first place and sadly
this has been happening for years across
the country there have been these pushes
to take evolution out of school and this
is you know sometimes just as insidious
is the demand that intelligent design or
creationism be taught alongside
evolution in science class and I've said
this before and I am very steadfast in
this belief I've really been covering
this issue for some time if you want to
teach intelligent design in religion
class have added right that is a
religious belief and it has its place in
religion class I would also say if it's
a general religion class you should
explain or teach creation stories from
other religions as well if it's a class
on Christianity then that is a perfect
place to explain that hey the view of
Christianity on creation is that there
was intelligent design or creationism or
some combination of the two but not in
science class and particularly not in
science class
as the one other story that you would
teach alongside evolution of how things
came to be the way they were even that
even the idea of saying in science class
we will teach evolution and we will
teach Christian creationism or
intelligent design once you add any
religious belief into science class
which i think is wrong you really should
be teaching the beliefs of I wouldn't
say all because there are hundreds or
even thousands but at least of several
religions on the creation of our planet
of our universe of the earth so this is
this is happening in the United States
it's not just an American phenomenon I
told you some months ago that in Turkey
schools are going to or probably at this
point did I believe it was starting this
past fall if I recall this fall this
current semester that we're in schools
in Turkey going to stop teaching
evolution endless public schools that
are actually teaching creationism in
science class Louisiana and Tennessee
probably the greatest offenders when it
comes to creationism and intelligent
design in science class and in January I
think it was within the first maybe the
first week after the inauguration of
Donald Trump a number of anti evolution
in education bills that were passed or
that were proposed rather so this is
having a real impact and I always you
know one thing I'm thinking about is we
know that beating right-wingers over the
head with facts is really not going to
bring them over to our side so how can
we talk to right-wingers in a way that
we might be able to appeal to their
sensibilities maybe when it comes to
education and math and science and not
going the religious way we should be
saying hey this is an issue of
patriotism right if we fall behind other
countries in math and science we are not
going to be able to compete and we're no
longer gonna be the best or something
like that or maybe it's national
security math and science Direct relate
directly to the development of defense
programs the development of I don't know
what else and we don't want to fall
behind other countries in terms of our
national security capabilities I mean
again these are not arguments that
particularly resonate with me but I'm
thinking of how we might be able to
appeal to the values of the right to
really explain why you've got to get
this stuff out and the Christian
homeschooling trend is part of the
problem because students are showing up
at colleges if they don't go to
Christian colleges you have students
that are being raised within the world
of Christian homeschooling and then they
show up in college where there's I
fortunately at most colleges not really
a place for creationism and intelligent
design in science classes and they're
unprepared so maybe if we appeal to the
right along the lines of patriotism and
national security we could try to make
some inroads but I am not particularly
optimistic because the trend is towards
more of this nonsense not towards less
of it